M it's God
it's it's
God it's
God what's going on everybody I got a
friend here with me today the black
doctor himself with a definite article
what's up my brother I'm doing well
brother how about you man I'm good man
so I I I got a dilemma here I got a
dilemma uh you know a problem was
brought to me about uh John chapter 1
verse one in the new World Translation
in the Jehovah's Witness Bible um so I
wanted to break this down today and and
just end this once and for all just for
people to be edified and how to deal
with this they'll come to your door
they'll bring their New World
Translation their little gray Bible and
in their Bible it'll read this in
John in the
beginning was the word and the Word was
with God and the Word was a god now
clearly all in all our Bibles it says in
the beginning was the word and the Word
was with God and the Word was God so
that's a here they use this as an
argument to go against the deity of
Christ to say that he's a Lesser God
than the father not the same God as the
father not one with the father in
essence but a Lesser God um you know a
lesser deity you will say so I wanted to
do a video today breaking this down and
showing how that is a Corruption of the
text and how they are distorting it for
their own means how can we answer this
and show that it's not a God but
actually the Word was
God yeah that's a that's an easy thing
to do really because all you need to do
is to understand a little bit of Greek a
little bit of Greek now the the
Jehovah's Witnesses will say well this
is the only way that we can properly
understand the Greek because if you look
at it if you look at the Greek language
um the word god there does doesn't have
the definite article so we'll we'll
we'll pull up the Greek text to to
figure out what their argument is fully
to so that we can fully see it and then
we'll we'll break it down uh break it
down so that we can digest it so here
what we have here on this first part is
the Greek language of the text this is
John 1 so here in John 1 it says in RK
halos in the beginning was the word
kaios a pronon which is and the Word was
with God and then you have kaios and hos
and the Word was God so what do we
talking about in relation to this entire
point we're looking at this last phrase
kaios and halagos and the Word was God
their interpretation the Jehovah's
Witnesses say and the Word was a God and
the reason why they argue this is
because the word Theos here it doesn't
have what we call a definite
article a definite article and the
reason why is is really interesting so
as we see here in the rest of like John
1 all of these other words uh holos
holos tonon and haagas here they all
have what we call the definite article
it's where the definite article would be
like thethe right yes exactly they would
say the word the god things things like
that and so they would argue that since
this word doesn't have the definite
article instead of putting the there you
would have a God so it's it's it's not
necessarily designating that it is the
true
God however they're not understanding
the the syntax of how Greek
works so before we even get there let's
focus on the rest of what John 1 says in
John 1 one do you want to do that Avery
yeah let's do it
let's let's break this down John chapter
1 verse one a in and Hal so let's look
at the first two words in AR in the
beginning what does this remind you of
Avery Genesis exactly he's referring
exactly to Genesis in the beginning God
created the heavens and the Earth in the
beginning was the word so he uses a
particular form here of the word was he
uses the term
a which is the imperfect the past form
of I me to be or to exist so what it's
saying is it's describing an action that
is in the past that is in the past but
is still going on it's still going on so
what John is saying is that as far as
you can place the beginning as far as
you can place the beginning the word
already was in existence and is
continuing to exist
that's good that's
good we also see in in in John
11b
K
so it says and the Word was with God the
term pross it it it means it means with
or or it's it's the preposition guard uh
degenerative so it's it's face to face
with it's for the sake of he is he is
near he is
beside so what he's saying so what John
is saying is that this word is not only
Eternal but he is with he is beside
someone else who is called God right so
this this this person has to be Eternal
and he also has to exist beside someone
else so when we look before eternity
before creation we don't see just one
person we see two persons yes then then
we see the the nature of this person
kaios and hos and this is where we get
to the main
point how do we understand
this Greek uh Greek Scholars those who
know the Greek syntax note that this
phrase falls under the rule known as
colwell's Rule now Avery do you know
what colwell's rule is I ain't got no
idea man break it down
sh okay I'll tell you I'll tell you so
what happens in colwell's rule is that
when it comes to these phrases you have
within it a noun or a pronoun that is a
anaris preverbal predicate nominative so
what in a world is an anaris preverbal
predicate nominative let's walk through
that the word anaris means that it
doesn't have the definite article we've
already SE seen that it is
preverbal that means that it is before
the verb a a I mean we can see that in
the text it comes before the word a but
it is also the predicate nominative a
predicate nominative means that when it
is
translated instead of being before the
verb it is translated after the verb
it's the
predicate so what we actually see here
with this rule m mainly what it's doing
it is
describing the nature of the
subject okay so let me let me give you
let me let me give you a comparison to
this let's go to First
John chapter
4 beginning at verse
8 and we'll look at the we'll look at
the comparison
here so the phrase says anyone who does
not love does not know God
because God is
love so here we have sort of the same
construct Hal Agape EST because the God
love
is so here we have Agape this doesn't
have the definite article does
it no it doesn't but it comes before the
verb and when translated it goes after
the
verb so what you're doing is you're
understanding that love here Agape is
describing the nature of haos here it's
describing the nature of God so it's not
saying that everything that we can
Define as Love Is God that would be if
we actually had the definite article
here but what it's describing that what
is true love is found in God God
properly defines true love and so as we
go back to John chapter 1 verse one the
same sort of construction is used
there so what we see is not a
description of Jesus being called a God
but literally it's describing the nature
of God himself that he is of the same
nature as God the father he is true God
a good break that's a good breakdown
doctor you doctorin
doctoring right now in the surgery some
surgery on this we got to do some
surgery on this so so the the the
structure of this of this phrase is
giving you the description of the nature
of the word yes it's telling you what
the word is by nature by his Essence wow
exact break down let me let me also
point out something here because the the
Jehovah's Witnesses they they try to use
this rule that if if the definite
article isn't there you add the word a
to it that's their that's their
consistent argument yeah
that's however that would make absolute
mince meat of John one absolute mince
meat let me let me explain how we'll
just go through one verse for example uh
John chapter 1 verse 6 now if we're
looking
hereo anthropos apostas para UHA Alto
yanas
so and none of these none of these words
have the definite article with them none
of these names or none of these pronouns
have the definite article with it but if
we used their rule to say that if there
isn't a definite article then you add
the word a to it for a noun or a pronoun
or an adjective you would say there was
a man sent from a god whose a name was a
John does that make any sense all no it
doesn't it doesn't and they would the
Jehovah's Witnesses wouldn't translate
it that way would it
wow that's so if they're
consistant then they've got to they've
they're they've got to make mince meat
out of uh out of john6 but of course
they know that it wouldn't the only
reason they make this argument is
because they know that this text proves
the deity of Christ and their theology
cannot handle
it emotional damage that's
tough that's that oh my goodness that's
tough BD wow so we literally have in the
same chapter verse six if we use their
rule they would have to say that a God
sent John yep John was sent by a God not
the true God a false god not the true
God a
god wow that's that's excellent because
there's no definite article before uh
what that's Theon right yeah the yeah or
the now here's here's a question that
was also asked about this about Theos
versus Theon ton Theon versus hos now
they try to argue that
uh you know the father isn't identified
as uh Theos but Theos is the general
term for you know any type of lower
deity lower ruler whatever um and so but
only the father is the on so is there a
reason why this is does taon and Theos
you know determine if it's really true
God and not true God or how does that
work no not at all I mean the term Theos
is just simply the term for God I mean
there a simple knowledge of the text
will will help you a simple knowledge of
Greek grammar will help you because
Theon the word Theon is simply the
accusative case of the same term
Theos so the accusative case means that
it is the direct object the only
difference between Theos and Theon is
whether or not the object that you
believe is God or is designating as
Theon
is the direct object if it's being
addressed as the the object that a that
a verb is is acting
upon there is no grammatical distinction
between Theos and Theon aside from that
it's not describing the ontology of
something it's not so and we see here in
relation to verse
six with
fu fu is simply the genitive form
meaning that he is the one sending or
it's it's belonging to
Theos it's that's that's simply it so
there there is no grammatical
distinction between the two they're just
they're pulling that out of nowhere I
think the only other person who tries to
make that argument is origin and I'm not
even sure if he holds that
wholeheartedly wow well there's this is
really good now this is something also
that I just wanted to touch on um if we
were to go with their understanding
right if we were to say okay that Jesus
in John 1:1 if you could scroll up to
John
1 is a God if Jesus is a god according
to them well the verse is saying then
that um actually you know what let's
actually use their's let's use their
book if it says that Jesus is the word
is a God this one was in the beginning
with God all things came into existence
through him and apart from him not even
one thing came into existence so there's
a problem here if it's a God then
they're saying that there's a God other
than Jehovah who is eternal and who
pre-existed all things who has always
existed and who was self- sustaining you
have two Gods now in the Jehovah's
Witness theology two legit
Gods so Jesus is eternal never come into
existence is the cause for everything
that has come into
existence but hold on a
second if they're saying that Jesus is
created by the father that he's created
by Jehovah it says all things that came
into existence came into existence
through him through Jesus that would
mean that Jesus was used to bring Jesus
into
existence Jehovah used Jesus to bring
Jesus into existence this is the problem
with their theology that dog won't
hunt that dog won't hunt so it's
either the word is one in essence with
the Father the same God who existed
before all things who is self-
sustaining or you have two Gods who are
self- sustaining who also created all
things and that's the problem with
Jehovah's Witness theology so that's how
you break this down it works against
them grammatically and it works against
them theologically they have no answer
for this at all well with that being
said black doctor man I want to
appreciate you thank you for breaking
this down man that surgery was nice you
cooked it guys please subscribe to Black
doctor his YouTube channel follow him on
Tik Tok he's live on Tik Tok we're the
cook Squad we be doing our thing so we
do this all the time black doctor does
this stuff all the time I hope this
helps you guys make sure you take notes
please like the video and subscribe to
the YouTube channel we're growing hit
the like button help it hit the
algorithm we'll see you guys on the next
time when we're answering Jehovah's
Witnesses
peace oh my God
logic
a